russian and ukrainian officials are
meeting today for a fourth round of
talks that's according to a senior
advisor to ukraine's president and it
comes a day after russian missiles hit a
ukrainian military base less than 15
miles from the border with poland poland
being a member of nato and that attack
killed at least 35 people here to talk
about the developing situation in
ukraine is retired lieutenant general
h.r mcmaster he was the national
security adviser to former president
trump and the author of battlegrounds
the fight to defend the free world and
he's got a new resume item to add to his
list pleased to announce he is joining
cbs news as a foreign policy and
national security contributor general
good morning
hey good morning great to be with you
and welcome back and welcome we're very
glad to have you we are no one better to
sort through the complexities of what's
going on in ukraine right now among
those complexities is this assault on a
military installation in the west of the
country 10 or 15 miles from the border
of poland as everybody knows and fears
anything over that border would trigger
a an article 5 a a counter-attack
potentially from america and its allies
how concerned should we be at this point
that this battle is encroaching on what
could be world war three territory
well you know i think we should be
concerned but you know i don't think the
world war three rhetoric is super
helpful right because it kind of plays
into into putin's hands and what he's
trying to do is is to threaten an
escalation of the war so that we will
throttle back on our support for ukraine
so i think it's it's important for us to
recognize that that russia is going to
do everything it can to try to interdict
the resupply for the ukrainians and this
is humanitarian assistance and also
replenishing some of their military
capabilities it's going to be more and
more contested i think in the far west
by these kind of long-range capabilities
but i think what you're seeing is that
that russia is is really getting
desperate right with not only this uh
this action to try to interdict the
supply routes but also you know with
this kind of you're trying to lay the
groundwork for maybe the use of chemical
weapons you know which is which is
concerning uh but then also you know
putin rattling his nuclear saber so this
is i think a real sign of weakness i
mean i think russia and putin in
particular is in real trouble
i hope you're right about that you know
talking about russia being desperate
there are reports that russia is getting
ready to ask china for military help and
economic aid can you see any scenario
that russia does that and if they do
what should the u.s response be
well gail they already have tremendous
support from china remember right before
the olympics they you know they they
both
called each other their bffs really you
know that
exactly and and what and what china's
been doing is providing cover for
russia's mass murder of innocent
civilians you know spouting the same
narrative that this isn't really a war
calling it a special military operation
also supporting these kind of false
claims of of military bio labs in in
ukraine so china i think i think this
ought to be hung around china's neck
this this horrible assault on ukraine
and and i think it's a tremendous moment
here gail for the for the free world i
think to shift the balance back in favor
of the free world and away from these
two authoritarian dictatorships
in general it's vlad you say it's time
that the u.s consider a no-fly zone and
boots on the ground in ukraine those are
actions that president biden says are
off the table why do you think they
should be on the table now and explain
what would happen if the united states
and russia come into direct contact with
each other and how things might escalate
well vlad i just don't think it's good
practice to take things off the table
why don't we just stop doing that right
stop talking about what we're not going
to do create some dilemmas you know for
putin i think for for too long we made
it too easy for him you know we vacated
the black sea we withdrew everybody from
from ukraine we said all the things
we're not going to do and you know in
retrospect it seems kind of almost that
we in some ways greenlighted the the
invasion with some of these actions now
i think the administration has done a
very good job in galvanizing you know
the free world against this russian
aggression so now it's time to take
advantage of it and and i think it's
it's time just to just stop talking
about what we're not going to do general
i want to pick up on the china question
one last time
while the administration has galvanized
the free world there's also some
coordination with the non-free world if
china does
give military hardware lethal hardware
to russia
to
further the war in ukraine
what should the u.s do in response if
anything
well we need to extend i think the
economic sanctions to china we need to
accelerate that anyway right because
this is a country that is committing
slow genocide of the uyghur population
this is a country where the companies
chinese companies have to literally act
as an arm of the chinese party as it
continues to to extend and tighten its
exclusive grip on power to stay to
extinguish human freedom in china and to
and to to continue to be aggressive in
the south china sea and against taiwan
and on the himalayan frontier with uh
with india so i think step a is hey why
don't we just stop underwriting our own
demise with china why don't we restrict
you know some of the financial flows
that go into china that are the
scaffolding that hold up their status
mercantilist economic model one that
they weaponize against us so i think
there are there are a lot of things we
can do to shore up supply chains and you
know hey how about like a sensible
energy policy uh as as well that that
that recognizes the tremendous potential
that the united states has uh to to to
not only satisfy our our needs uh but
also to to break some of the dependence
that russia has uh and to demonstrate to
china that hey you know china cannot
pursue its interests in this partnership
with russia but i'll say there's there's
a lot we can do in terms of sensible
long-term policies and i think this
ought to be a wake-up call right it was
germany's and europe's dependence on
russian oil and gas that at the
beginning muted our response hey let's
let's start managing these economic
dependencies on china and he also
recognized it's china that wants to
decouple on its own terms this is xi
jinping's idea of this dual circulation
economy
exactly right uh general mcmaster that
is exactly the kind of analysis that
we're proud to have at cbsc
we are so lucky that you're joining our
family thank you very much
hey privilege to be with you guys thank
you